[Applause]
obviously look we know there's a lot of
[ __ ] going on
and um sometimes there's stuff going on
like like this magnus stallion thing it
has all the elements
of something that you would want to care
about
right this is the problem with it right
it's like
everything about it i should care about
it right
it's rappers it's beef
it's someone got shot someone is 5'3 so
the guy is short the girl is huge yeah
right the you can't really call a girl
huge
tall tall you could call her tits huge
okay yeah
right like you bet yo you're a huge tit
and that's that whatever you got some
high ass tits
hi hi tall tits tall tits
huge presents she even that
even that president sounds like a dick
yeah
yeah oh i thought you were saying like
they're presents like they're like
like birthday presents like the lingerie
i bought for you [ __ ]
sale you fat [ __ ]
the thing with this story is we've been
trying to give a [ __ ] about it
for some reason i don't give a [ __ ]
about it and i blame tory's height
i mean this sincerely i think
there's something about how small he is
which makes me feel like even him
shooting isn't as bad
does that make sense he's defenseless
and like i don't know like i just don't
feel like he could aim
that good i think it's also the feat is
just such a weird yosemite sam
ass way and he black yosemite sam and
dory lanes you think you think before he
shot maggie
he shot straight down on the ground and
lifted up in his nikes
and then he just started shooting at the
[ __ ] feet and i was thinking helmer
foot
no you're 77 the little cowboy with the
mustache and [ __ ]
yeah dude i was thinking homer [ __ ]
elba
can you pull up a picture of yourself
this is if tory lanez was a cowboy
what's that one that's a woody
woodpecker
[Laughter]
yo do you think okay do you think you
would care more if tory shot
another rapper that was a man
bro if he shot like lil wayne or some
[ __ ]
that's he should fight lil wayne that's
a fair fight
they're dude it's like midge could tory
beat both of them up at the same time
you mean could meg could meg beat both
tory and lil wayne well no
if lil wayne and tory got on each
other's shoulders then i think they
could take her
if they had to combine into one rapper
yeah with like a big jacket or something
that would be
if they were transformers yeah yeah yeah
team megatron out here yo
i don't know why i'm not taking it as
serious like if a rapper of
normal height shot even at her feet
i think i would be like super offended
by it but there's something about how
tiny he is which makes it seem
insignificant
like i feel like maybe he was coming at
her and then like she just grabbed his
head and like
kept them there you know exactly yeah
yeah yeah
maybe that was it i don't know exactly
what it is why don't i care
about the story a man shot a woman
that should be enough
right i think right
why do why is this not serious to me
nice
it's serious but it's not
it's not
he should be deported and all that but i
don't know you're right
there's something what are you gonna do
with him put him in a little bird cage
do you think he can't put him in jail
you gotta put in one of them little
circle things and then gets
then she gets to carry that [ __ ] around
all day do i think what mark do you
think that his career is done
this is the weirdest thing usually if
you're a rapper you're involved in a
shooting it elevates your career
right but this could be the first
shooting that actually
and hurts a rapper's career and tori
could use all the elevation he could get
he could you think because he's short
yeah 5'3
do you think he's done forever is like
is his career is over yeah he's done
forever
i don't know something happened we
thought chris brown was done forever and
we saw the pictures
that's what made it hit home more was
pictures of a woman's face with chris
brown
he wasn't done actually tori don't he
don't he's not as good as chris brown
that's a good boy
yo who did something worse i thought
chris brown was
done so he's shooting the ground near a
girl's foot
worse than punching girls i wanted to
know that who
whose action was wars tories or chris
brown no neither is okay
if tory was like i literally was not
trying to shoot her at all
like clearly i shot at the ground okay
because the front of the gun is mad
heavy
hey do you think when he shot he
launched back like a cartoon hundred
percent
he actually made a very good case for
gun control gun control because you know
i say your kids could get a hold of the
gun
oh this game is what happened the baby
got the hold of the gun yeah that's true
100 bro nah dude this is
there's something wrong with this
there's something wrong with this here
but and i and i almost it kind of sucks
that chris brown keeps getting brought
in here because we're looking for
something to equate it to
yeah we're trying to make sense of it
yeah and for whatever reason i think
shooting a girl's feet
near a girl's feet isn't as bad as
punching a girl in the face repeatedly
well if he intended to shoot her feet
though i think that's what it was they
were having a dispute in the car and she
was like oh i'm going to go walk back to
where i'm staying
and he was like nah you're not walking
anywhere that's some mafia don [ __ ]
that's wild
he yeah that's the story that's some joe
pesci [ __ ]
again there's nothing to this story this
is the third time we've tried to talk
about how about this yo yo with no how
about this
yo meg tori stop being so boring though
it's not being so bored like how do you
have the juiciest story ever and it's
mind-numbingly boring canadian rappers
bro it's a canadian rapper bro
yeah stop it with this rah-rah thug [ __ ]
yeah get emotional
that's the theme of this podcast get
emotional
and make the stallions stop dating short
guys
you need how is meg the stallion not
with a [ __ ] tall human being
waka flock is tall enough uh luka dong
chitch oh yeah you give her that name
who could don chits
need it need to save
[Music]
shut his mouth forever bro yeah do i
mean because
he looks like a breed of of
he looks like an actual stallion
and if luca takes the one
a one appropriately named person for
montrez away from him bro
took his prized pony took his prized
pony
dog i'm telling you i think tori had the
fastest fall off of anyone i've ever
seen him i don't know i didn't even know
he
climbed yo 2020 he had the highest
climbing decline quarantine radio was
huge he was in a hot tub with kylie
jenner and meg the stallion
and now he's like the biggest bum of the
rap world
and might never make music again but
he's fire at making music he got to put
out a song though
and during the time he got independent
son he got independent at the height of
his career
and then [ __ ] up the whole [ __ ] that's
why there could be little conspiracy
theory going on here
there could be it really could be but
seriously i it's mind-boggling how this
is boring
and it's going to talk about the
snitching angle people are saying she's
snitched and she shouldn't have
and then all these people like yo
gangster shut up
i'm tired of y'all with your [ __ ]
rules about snitching yo
we're [ __ ] what's the rule yo can't
y'all get a constitution like america
you've nerds well technically if you're
not
if you're a civilian then you're allowed
to snatch and she's not part of this
shut up shut up
that [ __ ] didn't apply when you were
killing [ __ ] who were civilians
that were snitching on you
right the second civilian is snitching
on you for killing somebody in the
neighborhood all of a sudden they get
killed right you're not like well
they're civilian that's what they're
supposed to do is go to the cops
true or false ow ooh
i like some consistency for my gangsters
[Laughter]
i would like that tired of this [ __ ]
every gangster feel like they got to
talk about it
the code is a civilian is allowed to
snitch
but then they kill all the [ __ ]
civilians i mean i don't see that
happening
i'm sure it's just like word of mouth
type of thing isn't that like more of a
mob type of situation
you don't think that happens on the
streets and i think like the mob does
that but i don't
see too much like in the hood but then
again i'm not in the hood so i don't
know what the [ __ ] going on i don't
know all i'm saying is all these
[ __ ] gangsters were like
six nine not a real gangster six nine
not a real gangster and then he did some
not a real gangster [ __ ] and they're
like
oh no he's a rat he's a snitch so you
said he wasn't real
and then he did the [ __ ] that not real
gangsters do so why are you mad
yeah and now you're defending magnus
stallions
yeah yo y'all are boring
not y'all mega stallion tory lanez bro
y'all got a damn near duel you had a
[ __ ] duel
you had a shootout yeah they went full
hamilton on it they went full hamilton
one of them had guns though that's what
happened when you're talking about
i'm not talking about trying to talk
about meg's biceps yo
i really feel bad that megan hasn't been
able to spin this [ __ ]
lucy all this dead air yeah
god damn bro she was more interested in
talking about her wet ass [ __ ]
real talk i mean there's something
there's something no no this is
unbelievable
this is unbelievable we have an actual
shooting what is happening in america
there is a shooting that is involving
famous people
and we can barely feel five minutes of
conversation about it
without everybody in the room just going
we're [ __ ] bored
yeah guys nothing to say yeah yeah i may
deport him
sure but like six nine is the goat
six nine is more entertaining from
getting on his
private jet from his [ __ ] room
than tory lanez and make the stallion in
a [ __ ]
shootout
six nine is the [ __ ] goat
think about it bro yeah he's locked in
his [ __ ] house
locked in his house three music videos
make salad hasn't even written a diss
song about the guy that
shot her get to work put down the carrot
for real it's basic it's literally i
don't know what to say
i i cannot believe it there's there's a
certain point in time where you gotta
deliver
she did that one instagram live yeah
right
yeah no album release no song not i
think some of her friends
had some verses for tori right tokyo
jets or whatever like that do you know
who that is the rest of the city girls
oh yeah yeah there's more than one say
what
i didn't know there was more than one
the city girls
is plural in the name laurels huh i
thought you were just talking about her
like squad or whatever like the nikki
fans boys to men was more than one guy
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's crazy i know
it's more than one rapper since you got
a whole stable see how boring it is
[ __ ] don't even look that [ __ ]
up bro something's off
i need a little duval on the case little
duval needs to help that girl out bro
you got to turn this into something good
i think she's done with short dudes for
a while
[Laughter]
i think we'll do that she don't really
want to hear about shortstops
you